why direct another Hunger Games movie
because obviously it's a a very popular
franchise an exciting opportunity but
what about for you as a director always
continuing to hone his craft what was it
about this book that made you think I
have more to gain from playing in this
world again um you know part of it
honestly is working with the people so
it's you know working with Suzanne again
with Nina again we had such a great time
so that was great um I love being a part
of The Hunger Games world and because
Suzanne a book with new sort of thematic
material that was really exciting but I
really fell in love with doing a vill a
villain's origin story and also I love
World Creation in movies and so to go
back 64 years and be able to really
recreate this world and in a much more
sort of rudimentary sense was really
exciting jumping ahead a little bit now
to the games one particular uh one
particular sequence I really wanted to
ask about is the start of the games and
figuring out how to capture it with yo
because the first movie We Know it is
very chaotic a lot of handheld camera
work same with the uh Catching Fire too
but maybe a little more uh a little more
refined in that respect so what was it
like jumping off those to and figuring
out what best suited the start of the
10th games instead well I mean it was
like you know one of the things that is
always important to me is when you've
done games right so I knew that my the
beginning of my Games in Catching Fire
had to be different than they were in
the first one right so just emotionally
it has to feel different visually of
course very different kind of Arena same
with this visually very different kind
of Arena what I love about this and
because it's rudimentary is instead of
you know fancy like elevators and glass
pods and you know all of this they're
you know basically like walked in at
gunpoint or dragged in if they can't you
know and put on their spots and it's
just a basic Arena but of course these
explosions have happened and there's
Rubble everywhere and um that was really
exciting for me but it was really the
draw of and this is actually sort of
similar to Catching Fire the draw of
Rachel's character trying to find her
friend um and if you remember from
Catching Fire it's the same with Katniss
that Katniss is trying to find Peta and
she doesn't know where he is so sort of
two parallel similarities there bringing
up her trying to find Jessup in the
arena is making me think of all the
other tributes because in every single
one of these movies or at least the ones
that involve games one of my favorite
things about them is watching newer
actors that I'm less familiar with take
on these tribute roles and even with
less screen time making them feel like
full living breathing people so if you
could maybe isolate one actor whose name
we need to know who really surprised you
on set and made more of what was on the
page than you ever could have imagined
who would you choose and why jez only
one I'll take more you I'll give you
I'll give you two so uh I'll give you
three actually um so one is I and she
plays lamina and I she blows me away and
so I basically watched her grow up
because I'm a fan of Babylon Berlin and
she plays the younger sister to the to
the lead actress in that and grew up
sort of making that series but came to
us and doesn't say a word in our movie
and has the most amazing face is so
talented and with so game especially
running around up on top of that um
Cross Beam she's great Dimitri who plays
Reaper is also a phenomenal actor um so
he would improvise a lot and I think we
just got a lot of great emotion and
strength and kind of nobility from him
and then I'll say Sophia um who's you
know the young girl who lasts to the end
of the games who has Down syndrome and
she's just an amazing actress an amazing
kid and everybody fell in love with her
so I think those three are big standouts
for me casting on every one of these
movies Uno I love it same is true of
this one now a more familiar name I have
to bring up Viola Davis is just
absolutely perfect as Dr Gaul one thing
I've heard someone mention that I wanted
to ask you about is that it was her
choice to make sure the character had
two different colored eyes it was her
choice did she ever explain to you
precisely why that was important to her
no she just came up with the idea I
thought it was fun um you know weirdly
we had a long zoom and we chatted about
the themes of the book and how her
connect character connects to the themes
and my reference and I was a little
nervous to say this to her but my
reference for Gaul was actually Jee
Wilder's willly Wonka and that there's a
sort of a creativity to the job and this
kind of sinister
underpinning uh to everything and the
joy that they find in the creativity and
I think she kind of luckily totally
understood it got it was really excited
to do something different um but yes the
the the having the blue eye was her
idea